it doesn't matter nothing matters Wow
what happened in Malibu I gotta go so I
think a big turning point for our show
happens in that first season at really
episode 7 in episode 8 which are called
say anything and the telescope funnily
enough we only sent the first 6 episodes
to critics which looking back might have
been a mistake because I think they were
some of the first audience who didn't
really get what we were going for
because maybe we didn't tell them we
kept it a little too close to the vest
that right around the corner there are
these two big episodes that kind of
changed the whole thing and so say
anything is episode 7 and that's an
episode that's entirely told from
Princess Carolyn's perspective to up to
that moment everything almost anything
that's happened in the show has been
through Bojack a few episodes have small
be stories or see stories but they're
really heavy a story episodes and then
to kind of switch it and be like no
Bojack is the side story this time it's
really focused on this other character
felt like a bit of a departure for us
and we wanted to kind of explore what is
the damage that Bojack causes because
when he is your central character you're
with him you know he kind of falls into
some sort of wreckage and kind of steps
out and like dusts himself off and
wanders into the next misadventure but
we wanted to through Princess Carolyne
explore what is it like being another
person in this person's life what is it
like attaching yourself to this kind of
toxicity and that episode say anything
has the first really sad ending of the
series that everything up until then had
been pretty light or maybe weed and on
like a dark kind of joke but say
anything really ends on like a serious
kind of sad moment with this lonely
character and that for me was a real
sign of where we wanted to go and the
next episode the telescope I think kind
of pushes that into overdrive that's the
episode where Bojack goes to visit his
old friend herb and it's kind of set up
as this special episode where Bo Jake's
gonna make amends with this guy and he
doesn't and herb refuses to forgive him
for this thing that happened in their
past
and kind of because of our expectations
from watching television and because of
bojack's own expectations of you know
learning most of what he's learned
through making television he really
expects at the end this is going to work
out and it really doesn't and that also
was assigned or audience that we are
telling our stories a little differently
here and we're doing things a little
differently I like to lean into the
gimmick I like to say okay well let's do
it and then what does that mean and what
is a story that would necessitate that
kind of storytelling because I think the
the form should always match the
function I think you want to have a
format for a story that goes hand in
hand with the story you're telling but
that doesn't necessarily mean you need
to have the story first and then come up
with the format a lot of times it can
start with a four bag and start with
let's tell an episode without any
dialogue and so that episode
specifically fish-out-of-water you know
I came into the writers room and I said
I want to do a story where none of the
characters talk and that was a challenge
for me because like how do you justify
that that was the first challenge
because you didn't want to just be like
oh we're in Charlie Chaplin land you
know for no reason and that characters
are just kind of like look into each
other and mr. beating it up when it's
these characters that we've known for
three seasons to have full auditory
functionality so you need something that
kind of explains why the characters
wouldn't be talking kind of separately
to that Mike Hollingsworth is our
supervising director and he'd been
campaigning me to do an underwater story
because at the end of season two we had
an episode with a boat just like a
throwaway scene there's a boat in a dock
and you see like a gangplank of people
from the dock walking into the boat
there's another gangplank going off into
the ocean and you see all these fish
walking up the gangplank into the boat
so that like alluded to something going
on underneath the water and so Mike was
really fast in an attic what's happening
in underwater world let's tell a story
about that and that also provided some
complexity to me because I didn't
understand how you can tell a story in
the water with our characters who are
all air-breathing land dwelling mammals
right how do you tell a story underwater
with our characters who don't live
underwater
and then how would a even communicate to
each other I remember one night waking
up in the middle of night and I realized
Eureka these questions answer each other
on the one hand how do you tell a silent
story how do you justify it how you
telling underwater story put the peanut
butter in the chocolate and together it
makes fish out of water so then the room
try to figure how to do it and that
episode was written by Jordan young
Elijah Aaron two brilliant writers and I
said how do you write an episode like
that and they said we don't know let's
figure it out so we talked through the
story and and we you know kind of put it
up on the whiteboard like you do any
other episode and then when it's time to
write it they wrote the whole episode
just without the dialogue just you know
stage directions
Bojack you know walks through the rooms
of the hotel he looks out he sees a
bunch of sardines crammed themselves
into a room you know all these jokes but
just written out but they didn't know
how long to make the script because you
have certain benchmarks or certain you
have an understanding of like how many
words per minute are cute you know three
seasons and you kind of get a sense of
how long a script should be but we
didn't know the timing for for how long
as truth is they just wrote a script we
send it to Mike Hollingsworth our
supervising director who ended up
directing that episode and then he timed
it out by acting it he read through it
and kind of did the motions and timed
himself think how long is this gonna
take and so then we ended up getting it
to time based on Mike's estimates
[Music]
time's arrow in season four is also a
big benchmark episode I think part of it
was structurally looking at the season
and up until that point every episode 11
had been kind of a big bravura episode
for us in the first season it was a
crazy drug trip and the second season it
was this sojourn to New Mexico in the
third season it was a very tragic drug
binge but it really been the climax for
the season and in all of those episodes
they're mostly about Bojack behaving
terribly and ruining things and it felt
like Four Seasons Inn we can't go to
that well again we have to think of like
a new way to tell a story that still
feels like a climax for the season but
isn't just about Bojack being a schmuck
and so part of the idea was well can we
reverse that a little bit can we give
Bojack a bit of a hero moment which the
end of the episode does actually provide
and is a very cathartic climax for the
season in kind of an opposite way of how
most of our seasons operate and then we
were talking about this character of
Beatrice bojack's mother who the whole
season is suffering from dementia and we
thought wouldn't it be cool to tell a
story from her point of view and see the
world as she sees it as experiencing it
and that a lot of the kind of non
sequiturs that maybe she's been
motioning to throughout the season we'd
get further context for we'd see her
story in her life and I think a big
theme of the show is that nobody is just
a hero or a villain that all of us are
complex flawed individuals and so to
paint a picture of Beatrice who up until
this point had been pretty terrifying
and awful and painted as solely a burden
to Bojack in the present and a scarring
influence on him in the past but to try
to draw her sympathetically and make
people care about her that felt like a
really fun interesting challenge that
was kind of the beginning of that
episode I think meanwhile that episode
was written by Kate Purdy
who had written on our show since season
1 is a brilliant writer and at that
point Kate and I were developing this
new show undone for Amazon which plays a
lot with time and people falling through
time and unsure of where they are and
what they are so in some ways times
arrow is kind of a test run for her none
like what's let's play around with this
like will this be too difficult for our
audience to follow can we jump around in
time in this way you know through this
perspective without really explaining it
as it's going and it was very
encouraging I think the test was
successful and Peyton's want to explore
it more with our other show the only
thing that matters is right now this
moment this one spectacular moment we
are sharing together right saralyn
saralyn one of the tenants of the show
to me was that it was not a typical
animated show that snaps back to status
quo at the end of every episode I
remember having a meeting very early on
with some of the designers and the
directors and talking about the look of
the show and the feel of it and I
remember saying that you know if Bojack
has like a big party in Episode three
and all the furniture gets screwed up in
Episode four the furniture should still
be screwed up that you know kind of
we're used to shows that just kind of
ends and the next episode everything's
back to normal
and I want that damage to linger and
that kind of became a metaphor for the
show itself from the emotional toll that
the events of the show take on the
characters and I want you to kind of
feel over the course of that first
season and then in the subsequent
seasons that the damage that has
happened to this character and to his
relationships have had wait and have had
effect and that if someone gets in a big
fight in one episode it's not gonna go
back to normal in the next episode he's
he's still thinking about all the stuff
that's happened to him and the things
that he's done even he's not mentioning
it right he's not missing necessarily
saying oh I still feel guilty over that
thing I did four episodes ago but we
know it's still in there and
occasionally the reminders or things
will bubble back up or think about all
the history that's happened to him and
so I think a big part of that idea or
what goes hand-in-hand with that idea of
that the damage lingers is that people
will die and that when people die they
are dead and and and they're not coming
back and so it felt important to tell
that story they actually told that a few
times on the show now but we wanted we
wanted to do it we wanted to play out
the effects of these actions as we
put into place especially when you talk
about the end of season 3 if I like
we've been we've been setting up these
Domino's for a while like really since
you know I'd say the third episode of
season one and so by this point you know
we got to knock them over or what are we
doing are we judging us the best booty
OH Bojack no that is so degrading we've
had a lot of incredible guest stars over
the years and usually it just happens
because we write a script and we think
who would be a good person for this
script like who would be the funniest
person to be judging this booty
competition reality show
what if it's Felicity Huffman and then
we go to them and they usually say yes
which is crazy
occasionally we'll hear something like
oh this person's a big fan of the show
and then we'll keep them in mind if
there's a part from their play we don't
usually write parts for the actors you
the scripts always come first and then
we think about well who should we get to
do this and again our casting director
Linda lamontagne is incredible she just
kind of has an ear to the ground of
who's looking to do animation who's
looking to do our show specifically who
would be fun and surprising and so we
get these lists from her and it's like
oh my god you think they'd say yes like
we'll ask them and sometimes we ask them
and they say no but then they say yes
and it's very exciting but then we've
had people come on the show or people
that I've seen who have been heroes of
mine tell me they're fans of the show
that completely blows my mind like to
have Weird Al Yankovic who I like grew
up with come be a guest star on the show
and tell me personally that he really
loves the show my brain can't process
that I don't I don't know how to take
that kind of compliment and I quickly
change the subject to something else
herb I said I'm sorry yeah and I do not
forgive you you know I think it is up to
the individual viewer to decide for
themselves if Bojack is forgivable or
redeemable or deserving of that I
personally like to believe that we are
all flawed people and we are all
deserving of forgiveness and redemption
and grace but we have to work for it
we're not out it you know what I mean we
are
worthy of it but maybe maybe deserving
is the wrong word but it's open to
interpretation and I grapple with it I
don't always know myself and I think one
of the joys of making the show is
presenting these questions and not
always having the answers and I
accidentally sometimes when you don't
have the answer but you feel like you
need an answer and you put it in your
work it feels fake or it feels forced
and so a lot of times you know we'll
have questions we'll talk about in the
writers room we'll go back and forth and
at the end of the day if it feels like
we don't have a hard answer to this
we'll just kind of leave the audience
with the question and it's it's up to
them I think my favorite reaction to the
show that has happened quite a few times
now and at first I didn't quite know
what to do with it and and now what
happens I say thank you is when people
tell me that the show has helped them
articulate or identify something about
themselves that they've never been able
to recognize or verbalize before that
the show has helped them talk to a
therapist talk to a loved one realize a
truth that has always been there but
they've never quite had the words for it
now there's thing to point to and go oh
it's like that that was not necessarily
what we set out to do when we were
making the show but that feels so much
more rewarding to me than when people
say it's the funny animals it makes me
laugh I'm glad the funny animals make
people laugh too like that definitely is
something we aim for and we're very
proud of that as well but I would hope
that the the lasting legacy of the show
is that people continue to discover it
and it continues to articulate things
for them about feelings they've felt or
ways in which they've they've seen the
world and it allows them to maybe get
help that they didn't quite know how to
ask for before
nailed it